le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
suite au passage de birgitta les
sentiers de l'île ont été relativement
épargnés et ont pu rapidement être
rouvert à l'exception notamment du
sentier de bois court qui dessert grand
bassin ce sentier de 10 km est
actuellement fermée après avoir été
fortement endommagées par des éboulis
qui ont aussi affecté la canalisation
d'eau potable
en attendant sa réouverture et pour
maintenir la vie économique de grand
bassam le sentier ii molare a été
rouvert en urgence par le nf est un
raccourci a été aménagé pour permettre
l'accès au village
ces travaux sont financés par le
département
rencontre avec jeannick séry un des
gîtes heure de grand bassin qui nous
fait découvrir ce passage encore méconnu
du grand public
[Musique]
jeannick séry est un enfant de grand
bassin qui n'a jamais voulu quitter son
village depuis dix ans il tient avec sa
mère le gîte des orchidées la seule
solution pour pouvoir rester amis d une
douzaine de familles comme celle de
janick vie dans le village de grand
bassin
la plupart y tient également des gîtes
touristiques une vie et un métier en
autarcie qui demande une logistique
particulière car aucune route ne dessert
ce village ses habitants doivent
fréquemment emprunté à pied le sentier
de bois court pour se rendre dans la
localité la plus proche semaine c'est
presque tous les jours parce que on a
des enfants qu'il n'y a plus d'école en
paddock l'école c'est à moi quoi il faut
récupérer les enfants le soir et au
moins je redescends le matin et mais les
fortes pluies et le passage de bergues
ita en début d'année ont provoqué
consécutivement trois éboulis sur le
premier tronçon du sentier qui mène à
grand bassin donc ça c'est le troisième
éboulis juste après ben aguida des
éboulis sont les conséquences directes
de conditions climatiques qui selon
janyk n'avait encore jamais été vu dans
le secteur et la première année au mois
dé plus que il tombe autant c'est tous
les jours et aller est rempli d eau ce
troisième éboulis qui a coupé totalement
le tracé du sentier a aussi endommagé
une canalisation d'eau en contrebas
pendant ma guitare il ya eu deux
sections suillot qui alimente tout le
sud qui a été emportée avec les les
éboulis cette canalisation un déboucheur
pour diouf qui anime on te bats tout le
sud en noix depuis saint pierre jusqu'à
saint joseph petite île et la plaine des
cafres aussi cette canalisation a été
réparée mais doit être encore consolidé
avant de pouvoir procéder aux purge de
la falaise des opérations pointu et
délicates menées par l'eau nf sur fond
du conseil départemental
il ya des travaux qui sont nécessaires
et très technique ça demandera à peu
près six mois avec le nf et bien sûr des
équipes expertes et techniques pour un
montant total de 250 mille euros pour la
sécurité des usagers
le sentier de bois court est donc fermée
depuis le 12 janvier
par arrêté préfectoral et ce jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
une situation qui est vite devenue
préoccupante pour le village enclavé de
grands bassins dont la vie économique
est tournée vers le tourisme a entraîné
la rechute est vraiment les gîtes en
fait ben alaya plus de touristes du tout
en fait il ya des gens qui viennent par
curiosité
regardez l'état du sol typographie
peuvent faire une balade pas mais
finalement depuis depuis cet arrêté
préfectoral
une situation qui n'aura duré que peu de
temps puisque le département a rouvert
en urgence le sentier ii molard et le
second titine air-air pour rejoindre
grand bassin il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui une alternative a été
trouvé que cette île est est maintenant
accessible donc je voudrais aujourd'hui
rassurer l'ensemble des randonneurs et
aussi rassurer la population qui vivent
à combas 1 en leur disant que le
département est loué nef donc sont sur
le terrain et que tout aujourd'hui est
engagée pour que grand bassin retrouve
un aspect touristique économique et
social tout à fait normal la réouverture
du sentier ii molare permet depuis le 8
février
l'accès au village en toute sécurité et
pour que le temps de parcours soit quasi
similaire à celui du sentier de bois
court l'eau nf ya aménagé un raccourci
c'est simplement un passage
un peu plus court que d'habitude pour
rejoindre grand bassin pour le sentiment
l'arrêt vers 1
effectivement ce pâturage propriétaire
bien voulu
cet itinéraire secondaire habituellement
plus long que celui du sentier de bois
court est à présent réduit d'une heure
il faut compter deux heures de descente
au lieu de trois ce raccourci encore
méconnu du grand public est quant à lui
en cours de balisage
c'est vrai que c'est seulement les
habitants qui connaissent ce ce passage
son train en train d'officialiser le
sentier dès aujourd'hui ils vont faire
un pont balisage et au début janvier
vont mettre un panneau à la réunion ce
sont 850 km de sentiers qui tout au long
de l'année sont entretenus et balisés
par l'om f
grâce aux financements du département ce
suivi sur le terrain est primordial pour
assurer la vie économique des villages
enclavés des eaux de l'île le village de
grand bassin est donc de nouveau
accessible aux réunionnais et aux
touristes par le sentier ii molare
l'occasion pour tous de découvrir un
nouvel itinéraire et de nouveaux
paysages c'est un très très beau
chantier raison dragées on décroche le
feu
[Musique]
le conseil départemental confie
l'entretien et les travaux des 850 km de
sentiers de ville alloue élèves suite
aux fortes pluies et au passage de
belles guitares le sentier de boîte pour
qui dessert grand bassin est maintenu
fermé des travaux de consolidation des
canalisations et du réaménagement de
sentiers menée par le département et le
nerfs sont en cours et devraient durer
entre trois et six mois pour un coût
total de 250 mille euros à quelques
minutes en voiture du belvédère de bois
pour le sentier ii molare a été rouvert
en urgence il est accessible aux
réunionnais oenotouristes depuis le 8
février
launay fit aménager un rat possible le
village de grand bassin est à présent
accessible à deux heures de marche pour
connaître l'état des sentiers rendez
vous sur les sites du département et de
l'eau nf
[Musique]